if you go to quinnipiac university to
university in connecticut
and you do not get the vaccine
you will not have access to the internet
you will not i'm serious the uh
quinnipiac university
just sent out an email to students
announcing lots of fines and fees and
some of which are quite expensive
hundreds of dollars thousands of dollars
for not taking the the experimental drug
about coronavirus
the email also announced that
unvaccinated students
will lose access to the university's
wi-fi system if they don't meet the
vaccination requirements by september
14. so you basically just can't
you can be there you can continue to pay
them tuition and room and board but
you won't be able to do anything
now you might argue in the case of
quinnipiac you might argue look
whether the school is right or wrong
about the actual medical science and the
public health benefit what they're
trying to do here is protect the safety
of students maybe i don't agree with
their methods or even with their
with their perception of the threat of
coronavirus but
they're trying to protect public health
okay and maybe you can say that
maybe you can say that
in new york right now
the majority of black new yorkers are no
longer allowed into museums this policy
officially went into effect two days ago
it will not be enforced until
uh september 13th will not be enforced
city-wide but the policy officially went
into effect even though it won't be
enforced what does that mean uh
government's complicated i guess
especially in new york
but
assuming that the policy is the policy
if you're unvaccinated you can't go into
museums which means
that
well over two-thirds of black new
yorkers cannot go to i think the
vaccination rate among black new yorkers
right now is something like 28 percent
so
the majority of the 72 percent can't go
into museums anymore
one imagines this will raise some civil
rights questions
something about that seems wrong doesn't
it
hey i'm glad you liked that clip i hope
you liked that clip if you did just
leave a comment just say hey michael i
like that clip that'd be nice i
appreciate that it makes me feel good
uh if you have not subscribed please do
here at youtube but also to the michael
knowles show podcast on apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]